como lo había anunciado el líder de la
mayoría demócrata en el senado show
summer hoy fue aprobado el proyecto de
resolución continua que asegura la
financiación de las operaciones del
gobierno estadounidense hasta el 3 de
diciembre fecha en la que se tendrá que
volver a aprobar otra extensión o votar
el presupuesto final para el 2022 sin
embargo quedó sin resolver la ley que
suspende el techo de la deuda el senado
de mayoría demócrata tendrá que aprobar
esta ley antes del 18 de octubre fecha
en la que el tesoro se quedaría sin
dinero para pagar las deudas y eeuu
entraría por primera vez en default los
republicanos están presionando a los
demócratas a pasar el proyecto como una
ley de reconciliación que sólo
necesitaría una mayoría simple es decir
51 votos pero los demócratas no lo
quieren así porque argumentan que este
tipo de votación tomaría mucho tiempo y
quieren que los republicanos asuman su
responsabilidad fiscal asegurando una
mayoría de 60 votos en el senado sin
embargo la atención acá en el capitolio
está puesta ahora en la eventual
votación al proyecto de infraestructura
en la cámara de representantes pero la
disputa interna entre los demócratas
atrasaría esta votación que de darse
sería después de las nueve de la noche
hora de washington el desacuerdo
recordemos está entre los demócratas
progresistas que votarán en contra del
plan de infraestructura en la cámara si
los demócratas moderados en el senado no
se comprometen a votar el programa
social de 3.5 billones de dólares hay
que mencionar que el afán para firmar
hoy la ley de infraestructura es por un
límite de tiempo que se auto impusieron
los demócratas